[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
denny hamlin
going for a 3-p to daytona daytona 500
coming up this weekend
on fox and this would be his fourth
daytona 500
and of course i mentioned that he has
partnered with michael jordan they've
been good friends for quite some time
denny hamlin uh joins us now wait
i'm looking at you don't look like
you're you're happy what kind of mood
are you in today
good i mean my day's just getting going
so
we got a clean slate here all right like
you're in a race mode here or something
you seem kind of serious
what's what's going on i'm just ready to
get to the golf course man
wait that's how you're preparing for the
daytona 500 playing golf
yeah michael comes in today oh so you're
gonna go play with jordan
yeah now how much do you play is it per
hole
or is it front nine back nine overall no
by the whole got to get more action okay
now what kind of action are we talking
about on each hole who decides
uh well you decide on the first tee
yeah but is jordan deciding how much you
you're playing for no
no he just you know whatever you want to
play for whatever makes you comfortable
you know tiger said to me one time
whatever makes you nervous is what i
would play for
which i i can't play that game with him
right so
nothing makes him nervous immediately
i'm in a
disadvantage you could win the daytona
500 and still lose money because
no depending on how much you've had with
jordan you could give
no i don't sign over that check yeah no
i i'm good enough to where i
i never uh i never put in place
something that you know i'm gonna get
emotional if i lose
are you allowed to talk smack to him
absolutely
how does it work i mean i
you know he misses a putt he should make
which doesn't happen often this short
game is just
incredible but for me i just you know
you talk
you talk some smack talking about how
bad that putt is or how bad that shot
was
i like it uh you were born in tampa
but raised in virginia were you rooting
for the buccaneers
i was yeah um yeah that was the only
kind of connection i had to
either team so certainly was rooting for
the bucks there
have you golfed with brady before no
i've not
um which i mean when you watch the uh
the match
last year it was like boy he's he's
terrible and then all of a sudden
you know he he makes it from 160 out or
something
oh it was great that was one of those
where he shut up barkley like you know
suck on this charles yeah yeah
is is richard petty the tom brady of
daytona
oh uh i mean statistically speaking
yes because he's got seven right he does
and i mean
you know what's difficult is you know
back in richard petty's days
really there was five or six cars that
were capable of winning
the daytona race and you know now it's
just you know you've got 30
that are capable of winning so it's just
very very difficult like this fields
were all sprung out
strung out they didn't have the pack
drafting like they do now
uh where there's more wrecks so um not
to say it was
easier but certainly he was one of the
five or six that could win
uh when they got to the big track and it
feels like if you're going to win
daytona avoiding those
wrecks early and well even late too but
but how
how can you have a strategy to avoid a
wreck other than
be in first place and then you usually
don't have to worry about that wreck
well i mean statistically speaking like
uh
position 2.7 is the most likely to wreck
so the wrecks actually start
in the front um so there's really no
safe place that you can be unless you
want to just be dead last and
behind the pack totally so i mean i've
won this in
different ways either staying up front
or i've been
in the back and then sometimes i've been
in the middle and just somehow avoided
them so
i mean i think that certainly we've
defied odds um
in the last few years i i always say
this speedway racing where you have a
pack
it is a skill game but sometimes you get
unlucky
you know if you don't cause the wreck
you can get in it you know
usually another sports when people you
know your competition makes a mistake
you capitalize well
in this type of racing your competition
makes a mistake
you're liable to be in it so uh it's a
little different in that aspect
how much analytics do you guys use a lot
i mean i think that you know my team in
particular
uses quite a quite a bit of analytics we
always you know i always kind of know
my percentages what's the best place to
to be in
in a certain time but really i rely on
my gut
feeling you can see and feel when the um
the volume starts to get turned up
inside the pack and people are starting
to make moves that
you know are risky um and really that
intuition is kind of you know what i've
relied on over the years
what would it mean to three-peat well i
mean anytime you can do something that
no one else has done
i mean it's it's gonna be your biggest
victory and so
certainly for me i think that it would
be uh the biggest win that
myself and the fedex teams ever had is
is to win three in a row it would i deem
one of the hardest races to win
james dennis allen hamlin does anybody
call you dennis
no i mean not really
you know unless they want to throw out
like you know dennis the mess or
something like that
when i was a kid i got a little bit of
that but oh
it's still there still bothers you a
little bit ah
it might be a little touchy you know
what i was thinking jd hamlin sounds
like
a nascar driver i you know it's uh
it's interesting you know i never know
why i never knew why james wasn't just
my name um i mean that's what my real
name is
uh jd i could have went with that but
you know
my mom uh always used to call me little
denny my dad was
dennis and you know he was big denny
and i was a little denny and that's just
kind of how i i
always understood and answered is under
dinning we can
change it right now if you want to uh
well i mean
you you'd probably want to go with
dennis though right just to kind of now
i like jd no no no no i'm not going to
do the dentist the minute and i'm not
jordan here we're not trash talking i'm
on your side
okay okay i'm just thinking like jd
ladies and gentlemen
the number 11 car jd hamlin
i like that i i can go with that all
right it's official
paulie would you let nascar know that uh
don't call him dennis call him j.d
hamlin let fedex know as well all right
that's good i appreciate that
uh how often uh do you hear hey hamlin
nice pjs
uh a lot a lot i mean
yeah i thought i i think i saw you know
from the uh
analytics actually from that is that
it's been played now over 35
000 wait wait wait you have analytics on
the commercial you're in
yeah you know you know there was an
article put out
you know one that specializes in
commercials and airplay
and investments all that i was like 35
000
i mean it's on every channel yeah it's
definitely been the most played
commercial over the last three months
no question how long did it take you to
shoot that
uh just a day i mean it you know
actually the pj's line to be honest with
you was an alternate line
um that was you know kind of thrown in
right at the very end
um i forget what the primary line was
with her
um but i think she mentioned something
about
you know you're slow or something like
that but then
someone at the very own is like hey can
we get a pj's line can we get one where
you know she says nice pjs and then you
kind of react to that
like uh sure and turns out that you know
they knew what they were doing but i
loved your reaction you know you didn't
really
have any lines it's basically pjs
yeah i mean it was pretty natural
because they didn't tell me what the
line you know
they just said you know you had somebody
in the background saying
you know hey you're slow and i'd react
or
hey and then they were like hey nice pjs
pj
[Laughter]
hey you want to give a plug for uh the
uh team that you co-own with jordan here
before we uh let you go
yeah i mean this is a big year for us
obviously to bring jordan into nascar
he's obviously been a huge fan of it for
all of his life you know his dad used to
take him to nascar races i didn't know
that story
until you know we our friendship grew
but uh yeah fielding a car for bubba
wallace is here the only
african-american driver and he qualified
fourth actually uh yesterday for the
for the 500 so really looking forward to
you know
now owning a team as well as competing
which will be interesting no one's done
that
since dale earnhardt 20 some years ago
so
it's gonna be interesting dynamic but
you know hopefully i'm a great asset to
that team and
um you know i work for joe gibbs racing
one of the best organizations and so i
can bring
information over there uh to help us get
better so it's a big year for us and the
sport
itself it's great to talk to you have
fun and uh don't lose too much to jordan
here
all right that sounds good thank you for
being here all right
denny hamlin always good to catch up
with him